have y'all met ellen nope
y'all never hung out that's why i don't
judge i judge but i have not met her
oh okay unless you're honest about it
yeah
yeah i had a friend that used to be a
security guard for and he just said that
she was not cool but i just always heard
she wasn't cool but then also i think
whenever anybody gets into too much
power people think they're not cool
you know or people that i don't know
power just corrupts everything
yeah and there's a lot of jelly monsters
out there soft she's she's [ __ ]
killing it i like to feel she wasn't
even funny
shut the [ __ ] up she was a beast of a
comedian she was a comedian she was a
beast man
yes she has some pretty dope specials
adam carolla said she was always he knew
she was like a fake a phony because he
saw
her at a wedding one time and she didn't
dance the entire time he just saw her
sit at a table for three hours
no seizures can't do gangsters don't
dance we boogie
and do the rockaway yeah gangsters don't
dance we boogie
do you lean back but also oh because he
wanted her to dance all the [ __ ] time
but she talks about that like she's like
she stopped dancing that's why she hired
that twitch to dance because she's like
i'm getting sick of like whenever
anybody sees me though he's like dance
and she's like [ __ ]
man yeah again you know
oh yeah that should be your thing
dancing
get out there and dance exhaust that be
every time you go out
that's like dave it's like dave
chappelle you know i'm rich [ __ ] he
said he'd be like
at dinner with his kids yeah like i'm
rich [ __ ] she's like
dude come on man for ellen she had to
dance all the [ __ ] time
sometimes you don't feel like dancing
monday through sunday imagine if you
have an even crazier job you know like
you're a dog catcher you're like the
best dog catcher
i think think if you're that good
if you're the dog whisperer where the
[ __ ] that dude samus will you talk to my
dog yeah
no [ __ ] hey yeah leave a voicemail for
my dog
for something can you send my dog
attacks yeah man that's crazy what was
his name caesar milan i love that
really i love watching you ever seen
caesar get bit yeah yeah fantastic
yeah ago a golden retriever bit the [ __ ]
out yup it was a golden rule and it's
about
god damn time he's always got a pretty
good
that's what you get dog [ __ ] with
these dogs all the time
fake ass hoes boy yeah out of all the
dogs though he's [ __ ] with pit bulls
great danes well he's creeping the dog
some weird [ __ ] right here
he's always trying to get real personal
with the dog rubbing their asses and
[ __ ] all the time
you got to rub their ass he gets bit and
you know how we're talking about when we
get hit in the head with a football and
play it off watch this
just watched that yeah he goes no i'm
cool no it's not that big of a deal
damn
like she's like i'm good hey he's all
about dog rights i think the first thing
he did is threw a [ __ ]
face what kind of kick was that
that was a charlie brown kick to the
[ __ ] sternum of that dog
damn you gotta kick it though i don't
think so look at this
[ __ ]
that can't be in his training videos is
that rockets yeah what do you do though
yeah what do you do
you don't you do that axe kick the
golden achiever in the [ __ ]
heart but give me a ufc breakdown what
would you do what is this
this is the clinch right if anything you
punch that thing in the [ __ ] nose dog
like a shark
don't do it kick it in the heart and try
to [ __ ] kill it
i like how all his training went out the
window he's all you [ __ ] hound
he was like well [ __ ] i ain't buying his
dvd
look if an animal gets on you bro you
gotta [ __ ] show that [ __ ] what's up
especially a golden retriever man that
thing ain't [ __ ] bro
yeah and plus who knows where this dog's
from dude who knows what it's been doing
this dog could have been biting people
who knows that's not a problem though i
got bit in the ass by a golden retriever
when i was a kid and what'd you do
nothing went right nothing i should have
liked it in the heart
i didn't kick it in the heart we would
set traps we would dig holes and
make like fake leaves over it and then
have the dog walk over there
tight move yeah we would do all kind of
bad stuff because they had some
dangerous animals in our area
[Music]